Dewa, kanji bideo (video) wo shoukai shimasu.
Kono kanji bideo (video) wa, “Tobira, gateway
to Advanced Japanese Learning through Content
and Multimedia” no kyoukashou.
Ee, kanji ressun (lesson) ichi kara go made
no reading and writing no kanji wo shoukai
shimasu.
De, kono bideo (video) de, tsukuwa, ee, tsukawareteiru
riso-su (resource) nandesu keredomo, ee kono
Kanji Alive, kono uebusaito (website) kara,
e, ooku no riso-su (resource) wo totte imasu.
De wa, ressun (lesson) ichi no kanji nandesu
keredomo, ressun (lesson) ichi de wa kono
jyuu kyuu no kanji wo shoukai shimasu.
Mazu, saishou no kanji desu keredomo, kono
kanji, imi wa, city, market no imi ga arimasu.
So, kono top part desu yo ne, imagine a kind
of a roof of a house or some building.
Sorekara, kono shita no part nandesu keredomo,
kono paato (part), imi wa clothe no imi ga
arimasu.
So, there’s a clothe under a roof.
This must be a market or a store.
Soshite, eto, yomikata nandesu keredomo, nihongo
no kanji ni wa, e, onyomi, on reading.
Sorekara, kunyomi, kun riidingu (reading)
ga arimasu.
So in this video, onyomi, kore wa, subete,
ee, katakana de kakimasu.
Ee, kono kanji no onyomi desu keredomo, shi
desu.
Yoku tsukawareru no wa, proper name de, tatoeba,
Yokohama shi.
Yokohama city.
Ee, sorekara, toshi, cities, or urban area.
Sorekara, shinai.
Kore, city.
Kono kanji wa, within no imi ga arimasu.
So, within a city.
Ee, sorekara, kore shimin desu yo ne.
Kono kanji nandesu keredomo, people no imi
ga arimasu.
So shimin, kore, citizens.
Sorekara, kore wa shichou, mayor.
Soshite, shiyakusho, city hall.
Kunyomi no hou nandesu keredomo, kunyomi de
wa, ichi to iu yomikata desu.
Ee, tatoeba, kore, ichi.
Kore, market.
Sorekara, ano, ichiba, kore mo maaketto (market)
desu.
De, onaji kanji nandesu keredomo, stop market,
business market no toki ni wa, e, onaji kanji
ga, kore ga, shijou to iu fuu ni yobaremasu,
kiotsukete kudasai.
De wa, tsugi no kanji ni ikimasu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa, flat
and calm no imi ga arimasu.
Ee soshite, kono paato (part), this part itself
actually means drying.
So you put two seeds on the drying field to,
to make it flat.
De, chuuishite hoshii no wa desu ne, eeto
kono direction desu yo ne, kono two dot wa,
kono direction de onegaishimasu.
Kochira no direction wa, kore wa dame desu.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
De, yomikata, onyomi desu keredomo, hei.
Sore kara byou to iu no ga aru desu keredomo,
tatoeba, heikin, average.
Ee tatoeba, nihon jin no heikinjumyou, average
life expectancy desu yo ne.
Sorekara, heijitsu.
Kore wa week days.
Yoku tsukau no ga, heijitsu wa isogashii desu
ga, shuumatsu wa hima desu, hima da.
Ee sore kara, heikina, unconcerned.
Heikina kao wo shite iru.
Kore na adjective desu.
Sorekara, byoudou na, kore mo na adjective
nandesu keredomo, ee ningen wa minna byoudou da.
Human beings are all equal.
Kun yomi no hou desu keredomo, kunyomi de
wa, tai toka hira to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
E tatoeba, tairana, kore wa flat.
Tairana tochi: flat land.
Sorekara, te no hira.
Kore wa te wa daijoubu desu ne, hand.
Soshite hira.
So kore de, ee palm.
Ee sorekara, kore omoshiroin desu keredomo,
hirashain.
Shain tte iu no wa kaisha no shain nan desu
keredomo, mo flat, desu keredomo, employee
without a title.
Kore wo hirashain to iimasu.
Ee soshite, ano, hiragana katakana minna ga
yoku shiteiru hiragana katakana nandesu keredomo,
sore mo kono hira to iu, kono kanji wo tsukaimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu keredomo, kono kanji,
imi wa transmit to iu imi desu.
Ee kono paato (part), kono radical desu yo
ne, kono radical wa person no imi ga arimasu.
Sorekara, kore wa two, ichi ni no ni, two.
And imagine two people are sitting and transmitting
some messages or information.
So the whole kanji means transmit.
De, eeto yomikata nandesu keredomo, onyomi,
den ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, dentou.
Tradition.
Ee, dentouteki na youji ga nihon ni wa takusan
arimasu yo ne.
So, dentou, tradition.
Dentouteki, kore wa na adjective ee traditional.
Sorekara, dengonsuru, to convey message.
Densen suru, to transmit disease.
Ee sorekara, eeto senden suru.
Kore, to advertise.
Ee, tatoeba, yoku denwa nanka de, chotto dengon
wo nokoshitain no desu ga…
I’d like to leave a message, kono iikata
mo shimasu.
Ee, sorekara, kono byouki ni densenshite shimatta.
We transmitted.
Sore kara, kono shouhin wo senden suru.
Ee, to advertise this product.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Kunyomi desu keredomo, kunyomi de tsuta.
Tatoeba tsutaeru.
Kore wa, ma, to tell.
Ee kore wa transitive desu.
Tatoeba, kono messeji (message) wo tsutaete
kudasai.
Demo, intransitive wa tsutawaru.
Messeji (message) ga tsutawaru mashita.
Kiotsukete kudasai.
Tsutaeru, kore wa transitive desu kara messeji
(message) wo, wo tsukaimasu.
Ato, minna ga yoku shiteru tetsudau.
Sumimasen, chotto tetsudatte kuremasen ka.
Konna tsukaikatta wo shimasu.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu kedo mo, imi wa separate.
Sore kara, another to iu imi ga arimasu.
Ee toku ni kanji no ano hanashi ga nain desu
keredo mo, ee futatsu kiotsukete kudasai.
Ee, kono part desu yo ne, koko wa crossing
ja arimasen.
Kore kiotsukete kudasai.
Ee sorekara, eeto, kochira no part nandesu
keredomo, e kochira mijigaku, soshite kochira
wa nagaku, soshite kokoni ano hook wasurenaide
kudasai.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de betsu
to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, tokubetsu na, special.
Na adjective desu.
Sorede betsu betsu ni, ee separately.
Ee sorekara, bessekai.
Koko chiisai tsu desu no de kiotsukete kudasai.
Another world.
Ato, sabetsu suru, to discriminate.
Kubetsu suru, to differentiate.
Ee, chotto comment ga arimasu.
Ee ano na adjective desu yo ne, kore tokubetsu
na heya.
Ee demo, moshi adverb toshite tsukau toki,
tokubetsu ni atsukawanaide kudasai.
Don’t treat me specially to iu.
Ee ni, na, kiotsukete kudasai.
Ee, sorekara, ma jousei wo sabetsu shinaide
kudasai.
Ee, don’t discriminate women desu yo ne.
Sorekara, nani nani wo kubetsu suru, differentiate
nandesu keredomo, A to B wo kubetsu shite kudasai.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee kunyomi no hou desu keredomo, waka to iu
yomikata wo shimasu.
Tatoeba, wakareru.
Ee, kare to wakareta.
Ee separated from him nan desu ga.
Koko ano eigo de kangaeru to, from to iu no
de kara wo tsukau kamoshiremasen keredo mo,
kara wa dame desu.
Nihongo no toki ni wa itsumo kare to, to wo
tsukatte kudasai.
Hai, ijou desu.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa shape.
De, eto, kochira no paato (part) desu ne,
kore wa, imagine that gate of the shrine,
and before you come into the gate, you better
reshape your hair.
Ee to iu no de, kore shape no imi ga arimasu.
De, yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de kei,
aruiwa gyou to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, ningyou, doll.
Kono toki ni wa gyou desu yo ne.
Sorekara keishiki.
Kore form, format to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sorekara, seihoukei, kore wa square, chou
houkei, kore wa rectangle.
Ato, ano, keiyoushi, ee,
adjective.
Tatoeba i adjective, i keiyoushi toka, kou
iu tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee, sorekara desu ne, eeto doushi de, ano
keisei suru.
Kono sei, kono kanji nan desu keredomo, ee
naru to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sou, katachi, shape become certain shape,
ma, to form to iu imi ga arimasu.
Sorekara, henkei suru.
Ee, hen to iu imi wa desu ne, kore change
no imi ga arimasu.
So, katachi wo kaeru, to transform.
Ee, tsugi ni, ee, kunyomi desu keredomo, kunyomi
no yomikata toshite wa, ma omoni katachi,
to iu kore dake de daijoubu desu.
Tokidoki kata to iu yomi kata mo arundesukeredo
mo, katachi dake de daijoubu desu.
Ee, tatoeba, ie no katachi, kuruma no katachi.
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa decide no
imi ga arimasu.
De, eeto kochira no radical, ee kore wa minna
ga yoku shitteru to omou desu keredomo, water.
Ee, sorekara kono paato (part), desune, migigawa
no paato (part) desu keredomo, imagine some
headmaster or head man in a village to decide
the water distribution.
So the whole kanji becomes decide.
De, yomikata nandesu keredomo, onyomi de,
ketsu to iu yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kettei suru.
Kore chiisai tsu no de kiotsukete kudasai.
Ee, kettei suru, to decide.
Sorekara kesshin suru, to determine.
Ee, sorekara, kaiketsu suru, to resolve.
Ee kesshou sen.
Kore wa final game desu.
Ee soshite, keshite, kore wa never nandesu
ga, chotto ima kara ano tsukaikata wo, ee,
mite mitai ka to omoimasu.
Ee tatoeba, yuushousha wa kare ni kettei shimashita.
Winner, we decided on him.
Ee, nani nani ni kettei suru.
Ni wo tsukaimasu.
Ee, sorekara, kesshin suru, to determine nan
desu keredomo.
Ee tatoeba, daigakuin ni iku koto wo kesshin
shimashita.
Ee sorekara, kaiketsu suru, kore mo transitive
verb desu.
Ee, dakara kono mondai wo kaiketsu shite kudasai,
resolve this problem.
Ee, sorekara, keshite, kore wa itsumo negative
to isshou ni tsukawaremasu.
So, kanojo no, kanojo no koto wa keshite wasuremasen.
I will never forget about her.
Kou iu tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Ee kunyomi nan desu keredomo, kore wa ki.
Eeto transitive verb, kore wa nani nani wo
kimeru, to decide on something.
Sorekara nani nani ga kimaru.
Ee, kore wa intransive desu.
Ee, nani nani ga kimaru.
Nani nani wo kimeru.
Particle ni kiotsukete kudasai.
Hai, de wa tsugi no kanji mite ikimashou.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa harmony,
peace.
Sorekara yoku Japan to iu imi mo de dedekimasu.
Ee, hidari gawa no radical, kore wa rice plants
no imi ga arimasu.
Shape of some rice plants.
Sorekara, migi gawa, kore wa minna yoku shiteimasu
yo ne, mouth.
So if you have rice in your mouth, it’s
peaceful and it creates harmony.
And Japanese people, so likes rice, so, so
this is harmony, peace, and Japan.
De, yomikata nandesu keredomo, onyomi de wa,
wa toka o to iu no ga arimasu.
Ee, yoku tsukawareru no ga desu ne, konna
fuu ni, chotto prefix mitai nan desu keredomo,
washoku, kore wa japanese style tabemono.
Ee, sorekara, youshoku, washoku.
Tatoeba, osushi toka.
Sorekara, washitsu.
Kore wa nihon no stairu (style) no heya.
Ee, versus youshitsu.
Kore wa, ma, beddo ga aru yuna.
Ee, western style no heya to iu imi desu yo
ne.
Sorekara, wafuku.
Tatoeba, kimono, versus youfuku.
Sorekara, heiwa to iu peace no imi ga arimasu.
Ato wa, onwa, onwanna to iu no de, mild, toka,
gentle to iu imi ga arimasu.
Kunyomi nandesu keredomo, yawa toka nago tte
iu yomikata ga arundesukeredo mo.
yoku tsukawareru no ga, ma, yawarageru, to
soften.
Ee sorekara yawaragu, ee, kore wa to soften.
Kochi ra yawarageru kore ga transitive, soshite
yawaragu kore
ga intransitive desu.
Ato, ma nagoyaka na, peaceful na adjective
desu keredomo, nagoyaka na jidai desu, peaceful
time tte iu sonna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Hai, de wa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa target.
Sorekara, yoku tsukawareru no wa desu ne,
ee adjectival suffix, na adjective wo tsukuru
suffix toshite mo yoku tsukawaremasu.
De, kanji no hanashi, ma, imi wa nain desu
keredomo, ano, kore, kunyomi de mato tte iun
desu keredomo, ma, kono imi wa desu ne, sono
nihon no archery, kyuudou no kore, mato, target
desu.
De, onyomi nan desu keredomo, teki.
Tatoeba, nihon teki na, japanese.
Rekishi teki na, historical.
Ee sorekara, kokusai teki na, international.
Yousuru ni, meishi ni tsuite, ee, adjective
wo tsukuru.
Ee sou itta function ga arimasu.
Kore, shiteki na, kore wakaru deshou ka, kore,
private to iu imi desu.
Ato, tekikaku na, kore wa precise toka, appropriate.
Sorekara, mokuteki, purpose.
Kono toki ni mo, kono teki ga tsukawaremasu.
Ato, kunyomi dewa, mato.
Ee, saki mo mimashita keredo mo, kono, target
no imi ga arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa build
no imi desu.
De, kochira no kono hidari gawa, kono radical
nan desu keredomo, kore, imi toshite wa, to
move to stretch, sonna imi ga arimasu.
De, kono paato (part) desu yo ne, kore, you
can imagine someone holding some pens or pencil.
So together, moving the materials based on
a plan drawn by hand, meaning to build.
De, yomikata desu keredomo, onyomi de wa,
ken.
Tatoeba, kenchiku, architecture.
Sorekara, kensetsu suru, kore wa to construct.
Ee, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, ta to iu no
ga arimasu.
Ee, nani nani ga tatsu.
Kore wa intransitive desu.
Tatoeba, atarashii biru ga tatsu.
Ee, sorekara sono transitive version desu
yo ne, kore, tateru.
Atarashii biru wo tateru.
Particle wo kiotsukete kudasai.
Ato, ano chotto yomikata ga, ano, exception
naru desu keredomo, kore, tatemono.
Ee, buildings.
Ee, sorekara, nikai date, sangai date tte
iu youna, two stories arui wa three stories.
Ee, konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa beautiful,
sorekara beauty no imi ga arimasu.
Ee, kochira no ue no paato (part) desu yo
ne, kore wa ma imi toshite wa sheep.
Ee sorekara shita, koko wa, ma, dai.
So, imagine a big sheep is beautiful to iu
no de, together, beautiful, beauty no imi
ga arimasu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de
wa bi.
Tatoeba, bijin, bijou.
Ma dochira mo beautiful women desu keredomo.
Sorekara, bijutsukan, museum.
Sorekara, biyouin, beauty salon.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Ato, ee kunyomi de wa, utsukushii, daijoubu
desu ne, utsukushii, beautiful.
Ee, sorekara, kore wa chotto tokubetsu na
yomikata ni narun desu keredomo, oishii.
Kore utsukushii to iu, ee, kono kanji wo tsukaimasu.
Ee, kono, ee, kono gohan wa oishii desu ne,
delicious to iu.
Ano, mochiron hiragana de kaitemo iin desu
keredomo, ano nihonjin no hito de ko iu fuu
ni oishii, utsukushii to iu utsukushii aji,
taste, beautiful taste to iu kakikata wo suru
hito mo imasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji no imi wa island no imi desu.
De, eeto kono part, kore wa, ma, minna wa
yoku shitteiru, mountain.
Sorekara, ue no, sotogawa no hou, kore, tori,
bird.
Kono you na katachi shiteru wake nandesu keredomo,
imagine a mountain surrounded by birds, it's
an island.
Ma, konna oboekata de daijoubuka to omoimasu.
Ee, sorede desu ne, yomikata, onyomi nan desu
keredomo, tou.
Tatoeba, nihon rettou.
Japanese archipelago.
Sorekara, hantou, peninsula.
Sorekara, mujintou, kore wa hito ga inai shima
to iu imi desu yo ne.
De, kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, eeto,
shima, island.
Sorekara shimaguni, island country.
Takarajima, treasure island nan desu ga, yoku
nihon wa yottsu no ooki shima de dekideiru,
hokkaido, honshu, shikoku, kyushu desu keredomo,
yottsu no ooki shima to iu tsukaikata.
Sorekara, nihon wa shimaguni da, sou desu
yo ne, nihon wa yottsu no ooki shima to, sorekara,
itsukutsu mono, takusan no shima kara, shima
de dekite imasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji ni iki masu.
Ee, kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa difference.
Kono kanji de chotto kiotsukete hoshii no
wa desu ne, koko to kono line wa hitotsu no
line ja arimasen.
Desukara kono fuu ni, one line wo tsukauno
wa yamete kudasai.
De, yomikata nandesukeredo mo, onyomi de wa,
sa.
Ee, tatoeba, sa, ma difference.
Nihon to america de wa bunka no sa ga takusan
arimasu.
There are lot of cultural differences to iu
tsukaikata.
Sorekara, taisa.
Kore wa ooki ni sa, big difference.
Jisa, kore wa ii desu ne, jikan no sa to iu
no de, time difference.
Minna ga yoku tsukau, sono, jet lag to iu
no wa, jisaboke, to iu kotoba ga arimasu.
Sorekara, kojinsa, kojin to iu no wa individual.
So individual difference.
Sore kara, sabetsu suru, to discriminate.
Ee, jinshu sabetsu, kore wa racial discrimination
to iu kotoba desu.
Ato, kunyomi nandesu keredomo, ee chotto idiomatic
tsukaikata kamo shiremasen.
Tatoeba, sashiagari, for the time being.
Ee yoku tsukau no ga desu ne, ma soshiagari
daijoubu deshou.
Sorekara, sashitsukae nakereba, if it's not
a problem, nani ka wo onegai suru toki ni
yoku tsukaimasu.
Sashitsukae nakereba, oshiteitadakenai deshouka.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa, remain.
Sorekara, ruthless no imi ga arimasu.
Eeto, kochira no amo hidari gawa desu yo ne,
kore wa, kore shinu, to die nan desu keredomo,
imi toshite wa, ma, death, dying.
Konna imi ga arimasu.
Sore kara, migi gawa, kore, ma, imagine this
kanji, shallow.
So, one way to remember this character is
the remain of a shallow death is ruthless.
Amari ii oboekata jya nai deskeredo mo, yomikata
no hou in hairimasu.
Yomikata, onyomi nan desu keredomo, zan.
Tatoeba, zannenn na, unfortunate.
Zannen na kekka datta nee, unfortunate result.
Sorekara, zangyou, overtime work.
Ee, nihon no kaisha de wa mada zangyou ga
takusan aru, sou desu yo ne.
Eeto, overtime work ga takusan aru.
Sorekara, zandaka, ee kore wa bank balance
no koto desu.
Ee boku no ginkou kouza, ginkou koza tte no
wa bank account, no zandaka wa zero da.
Tsugi ni, kunyomi no hou nandesu keredomo,
ee, kore intransitive sore kara transitive
no pair desu.
Kore ga nokoru, nani nani ga nokoru, intransitive.
Sorekara, nani nani wo nokosu.
Kochira ga transitive.
Okane ga nokoru.
Sorekara, okane wo nokosu.
Ma, kono baai ni wa, leave some money to iu
you na imi ni nattekimasu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa special no
imi ga arimasu, de, eeto, kochira migi gawa
kore wa minna yoku shitteimasu ne, kore wa
temple.
Sorekara hidari gawa kochira no radical,
kore wa, cow, ushi desu.
So some temple actually have a special treatment
for cows to iu no de, ma kore eeto together
it means special.
Yomikata nandesu keredomo, kunyomi wa arimasen.ee,
de onyomi dake nandesukeredo mo, toku to iu
yomikata wo shimasu.
Ee, tatoeba, tokuchou, feature.
Tokkyuu, ee kore express train desu yo ne,
sorekara, tokubetsu na, special.
Dokutoku na, unique.
Chotto reibun wo mite ikimashou.
Tatoeba desu ne, nihongo no tokuchou, feature,
nihongo no tokuchou wa nandeshouka.
Tatoeba, nihon no tokuchou wa keigo desu,
toka, sonna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Ato, ano tokkyuu ni notte kudasai, express
train.
Ee sorekara, kore wa tokubetsu na ryouri desu,
special cuisine.
Ee sorekara, dokutoku na aji ga shimasu nee.
Aa, this has a unique taste to iu tsukaikata
desu.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa attain.
De yoku tsukawareru no wa desu ne, plural
suffix toshite mo yoku tsukawaremasu.
Ee chotto iroiro paato (part) mite ikimashou.
Kono paato (part), kore wa sheep.
Ee sorekara, kono ue no dokoro, kore wa soil
toka, ground, doyoubi no do desu yo de.
Sore, kono radical, kore wa, nihon go de wa
shinyou to iu desu keredomo, imi toshite wa
road, walk, to advance to iu imi desu.
So, if a shephard can bring or move a sheep
to a particular ground, then he attains a
goal, so attain to iu imi desu.
De, yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee onyomi
de wa, tatsu.
Tatoeba, toutasu suru, to reach.
Tsuki ni toutatsu shimashita.
Sorekara, hattatsu suru, kore wa, ee, to develop.
Kore wa intransitive desu.
Eeto, tatoeba, robot no gijyutsu ga hattatsu
shiteimasu.
Ma, to develop tte iu ka, advance no you na
imi nan desu keredomo.
Sorekara, haitatsu suru, kore wa, to deliver.
Tatoeba, tegami wo haitatsu shite kudasai.
Aruiwa, yuubin haitatsu, by mail to iu are
desu ne.
Sorekara, sokutatsu, kore wa express delivery.
Ee tatoeba, kono tegami wo sokutatsu de okutte
kudasai, by express delivery, to iu tsukaikata desu.
Ee, kunyomi no hou nan desu keredomo, kore
wa, ano plural form no suffix toshite tsukwaremasu.
Tatoeba, watashitachi, kore wa watashi wa
i desukeredo mo, watashitachi, to iu no de,
we.
Kodomo, kore wa, child.
Demo kodomo tachi, to iu no de, kore explicitly
express plurality desu, kodomo tachi.
Ee sorekara gakusei tachi.
Tomodachi.
Kore hitotsu no ano kotoba nandesu keredomo.
De, animals desu yo ne.
Ningen igai no mono.
Ee kore de mochiron tachi, kono kanji wo tsukattemo
iin desu keredomo, nihon jin no hito de yoku
hiragana wo tsukau hito ga imasu.
Ee sorekara desu ne, hontachi tokka, inanimate
object ni wa, konno tachi wa tsukawanai de kudasai.
Dewa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desu keredomo, imi wa warm.
De, kono paato (part), kono radical, ee mo
minna mo shitte masu ne, water.
Ee soshite kono paato (part), sun.
Ee soshite kono kanji nandesu keredomo, kono
paato (part), kore by itself, plate, sara desu.
So if you put the water on the plate under
the sun the water becomes warm.
So the whole thing meaning wa warm.
No imi desu.
De, eeto yomikata nandesu keredomo, onyomi
de wa on.
Tatoeba, ondo, temperature.
Sorekara, kion, kore wa air no imi ga arimasu
kara, air temperature.
Sorekara taion, kore kara desu yo ne, body
temperature.
Sorekara, kore, ondokei, ee ondo.
Kore temperature desu keredomo, kono kanji,
kore hakaru, to measure no imi ga arimasu.
So, thermometer no imi desu.
Ee, ato, ee minna ga daisuki na onsen, hot
spring.
Ato, ondan na, mild.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Ee, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, atata.
Ee, kore mo ee transitive intransitive no contrast
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, nani nani wo atatameru.
Kore wa transitive.
Suupu (soup) wo atatamete kudasai.
Sorekara, nani nani ga atatamaru, kore wa
intransitive desu.
Suupu (soup) ga atatamarimashita.
Ato, ma, adjective de atatakai, warm, desu
yo ne.
Mou jyuunigatsu ni haitta kedo, atatakai desu
ne.
Konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee, kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa to perceive
sorekara to remember.
Awake to iu imi mo arimasu.
De, eeto kono paato (part) nan desu keredomo,
ue no paato (part) kore, kore manabu desu ne.
To learn, gakkou no gaku nandesu keredomo.
So, learn.
Soshite, kono naka shita no tokoro wa miru,
to watch desu ne.
So you learn something through watching.
So it’s perceive, or remember to iu imi
nan desu keredomo.
Yomikata, ee, onyomi wa kaku to iu no yomikata
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, kankaku, sense, sensation.
Ee sorekara kakugo suru.
Ee kore to prepare, be ready to iu youna imi
nan desu keredomo.
Ato jigakusuru, to become aware of oneself.
De, kunyomi no hou kore wa oboeru.
EE, tatoeba kono kanji wo oboete imasu.
I remember this kanji.
Mochiron, ano oboete kudasai te ma, memorize
this kanji to iu imi ni mo arimasu.
Sorekara, sameru, samasu.
Kore mata intransitive sorekara transitive
no pair nandesu keredomo.
Sameru, kore wa intransitive.
Me ga samemashita.
I got up, I woke up to iu imi desu.
Ee sorekara, me wo samasu, kore ga, eeto ma,
I woke up nan desu keredomo,
tatoeba, me wo samashite kudasai.
Wake up to iu, konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Ato, minna ga yoku shitteiru mezamashi tokei,
kono kanji wo kakimasu.
Hai. Dewa tsugi no kanji desu.
Ee kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa explain,
theory, sorekara opinion konna imi ga arimasu.
De, eeto kono radical desu keredomo, mou shitte
masu minna, kore wa ano, language ni ee language
sore kara speaking ni kankei ga shita mono
nan desu keredomo.
So you can imagine someone with a big mouth
talking and explaining or expressing his theory
or opinion, konna imi desu.
De, eeto yomikata nan desu keredomo, ee, onyomi
de setsu, sorekara
zei to iu yomikata ga arun desukeredo mo.
Tatoeba, setsumei suru, to explain.
Sorekara, settoku suru, to persuade.
Enzetsu suru, kore wa to give a speech.
Sorekara shousetsu, kore wa novel.
Li desu ne. Shousetsuka, kore wa
shousetsu wo kaku hito.
Ee sorekara kasetsu, hypothesis.
Konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Ee, kunyomi nan desu keredomo, amari tsukawanai
katto omoun desukeredo mo, toku to iu, kore
ma to explain nan desu keredomo, ee, chotto
tokubetsu na ii kata nan desu keredomo, ma
bukkyou ga toku oshie, the teaching the Buddhism
explain, aruiwa persuade, sonna imi desu.
Hai. Dewa, resson (lesson) no ichi no saigo no
last character of lesson 1.
Ee, kono kanji desukeredo mo, imi wa choose.
Sorekara, elect no imi ga arimasu.
De, eeto, kono paato (part) nan desu keredomo,
kono kanji by itself actually means individual.
So, you see two people, shita kono paato (part)
nan desu keredomo, kore tomo ni, together
no imi ga arimasu.
So two people together going to the market
and choosing which goods to select,
sonna imi desu. Desu ga. So
the whole thing means to choose.
Aruiwa elect no imi desu.
De yomikata nan desu keredomo, onyomi de sen.
Tatoeba sentaku suru, to choose.
Senkou suru, ee select.
Sorekara tousen suru, kore wa to be elected.
Ato, senkyou, election desu yo ne, daitouryou
senkyou.
Daitouryou tte iu no wa president.
So daitouryou no senkyou no imi desu.
Sorekara, senshuu.
Kore wa player.
Yakyuu no senshuu, orinpikku (Olympic) no
senshuu, konna tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Kunyomi wa erabu, ee nani nani wo erabu.
Transitive verb desu.
Tatoeba, suki na mono wo erande kudasai.
Choose whatever you like.
Konna tsukaikata desu.